あまりにもでっかい絵だったら
もう見たっても面白くも何もない
それは遠く 遠くへ 遠くへ行って見なくちゃいけない
遠くへ行くと見えなく
また帰って見えなくなる
全体的には見えるんだけど
はっきりと見えなくなっちゃう
そこで近寄ってくると
あまり大きい絵だから
また全体的にはつかまれなくなっちゃうし
ですから この人の目にちゃんと認識的に受け取れるって大きさがあるんです
それまた個人差があります
人間みんな同じだから同じ大きさでしっかり見えるわけじゃないんです
個人差もそれなりにあります
ですから その個人が自分にはしっかりと
またいくらかの大胆なスケールで大きく
でもつかまれるぐらいの大きさに大きくしてみる
また 自分の意識でコントロールして小さくしてみる
元のところに戻ってもらう
で また大きくしてもらうとか
そうやって訓練すると
かなり自分が上手になるんですね
この心で受け取ったこの対象
まあ幻想 現象です 幻想ですが
その幻想を まあそれがね
コントロールできるようになってくる
そこで あの 自動的に ほら
また変わって その対象が変わって
なんかもっと面白い ものすごい強力な色に変化しちゃうんですね
だから ものは強力な色に変化するっていうことは
光に変わるっていうことなんですね
そこでこの土色のものから
なんとなくそれはまあゆっくりと光ってきて
まあものすごくまあ光ってくるんですね
で そこはこの次に書いている何ニミッタでしたっけ？パティバーガ？パティバーガニミッタと言うんですね
瞑想 で そこまでなってくると
心の状態はどうなりますかというと
で 心にはこの第一禅定と似ている真相はほとんど揃っているんです
仏教で見ているのは心の状態なんです
その場合 その時あなたの心の状態は何ですかというと
ヴィタッカとヴィチャーラとピーティとスケーとパティバガという第一禅定の特色ありますね
慈悲と喜と楽と一貫性という五つの特色
そこは思い存分心にあります
そこでサマーディが生まれちゃうんですね
瞬間に だからサマーディが生まれるということは
この現代風に言うと ある瞬間でこの対象があって
この主体客体という瞬間が消えちゃうんですね
瞬間だけですけど 主体客体ということはもうパッと消えちゃう
だから自分でコントロール何もできない瞬間があるんです
自分消えちゃう 自分というものは消えちゃうんだけど
ちゃんと慈悲 まあ考え方とかそこにあるんですけど
私がやってるっていう気持ちがそこで消えちゃうんですね
だから瞑想の言葉ずっと唱えてるんです
パタヴィ パタヴィ パタヴィとかね
唱えてるんだけど 私がやってるんだっていう気持ちは
まあ消えてしまっちゃう
誰かがやらせてるわけでもなくて
自分がやってるわけでもなくて
ただこの主体客体瞬間が消えちゃう
消えて 次の瞬間また我に戻りますけど
あの瞬間はサマーディなんです
第一なんです でもそれだけでは立派なサマーディとは言えません
それから私はサマーディのところでずっと説明しましたからね
あの五慈再という五つの訓練して
いつでも入ったり それからそこから立ち上がったりする訓練しなくちゃいけない
それからこの最初は瞬間なんですけど
この我ない 我がない瞬間はちょっと伸ばしてみる
そうやって伸ばしてみる訓練もして
我がない瞬間で これずっと三十分でも一時間でもいられるんだったら
それはもう究極的な幸福感じちゃうんですね
苦しみが消えちゃうんです
全て苦しみが私が 我がいる時生まれるんです
主体客体離れてるんだから
我という感覚が消えた瞬間で究極的に幸福が感じちゃうんですね
だからサマーディできる人はまあもうfrequentlyって
やっぱり何て言いますか
よく入った方がいいと
それは脳にとってもすごくいいことなんです
だから脳にしてもかなり苦しいんですよ
私がいて考えなくちゃいけないんだから
だから私がいるということは攻撃的な思考なんですね
攻撃的な認識なんですね
だから脳にもリラックスできないんです
私という 我がいるという感覚が消えたら
あの リラックスできるんですね
ですから まあそれは戦場のレベルで言ったっても何の意味もないんだけど
まあいくらかこの自分のこの必死になって死にかけてるプロセスをほんのちょっと一旦停止してもらったような感じなんですね
気持ちとしては だから休んだような感じなんですね
私たちは瞬間も休んでないんです
休めないんです だからこのサマーディ状態に入ったら
なんか体も心もちょっと休んだか
という感じになります
ですから この体にもそれ結構いい影響になるし
心にもすごくいい影響にはなります
それは第一戦場のところで
だからといって考えることはそのまま続けちゃいます
第２戦場っていうのは
まあ前説明しましたから
また繰り返す必要はないんだけど
この あの 我がなくなっても考え方があったんだからと
だから考え方もなかった方がもっと
楽じゃないかなと ということで
さらに同じ瞑想を訓練していくんですね
ものすごく上手に身についちゃったら
なんのことなく簡単にその状況に入っちゃうんですね
そうすると考えなくても構いません
それは 第２戦場で で ３
というのは この激しい喜びの波があるんだから
やっぱりそれも我から私がということが隠れているんですね
この激しい喜びの波もない方がもっといいんじゃないかなと
さらに訓練しちゃうと
激しい喜びのあの飴玉なくてもその状態に入ることができる
第4戦場っていうのは
この全部このシャーの状態で
ただ単にもう土のあれと一緒になってるだけで
あまり喜びも何もない状態
その方が一番この心が落ち着いている
第4戦場 それ以上不可能
第4戦場で終わります
仏教ではそれ以上不可能だと
心理的に心象の働きから入っているんですね
だから問題は他の世界ではそこまでやってるかないかっていうことなんですね
なかなか無いんですけどね
今この話してる途中で思い出したんだけど
このこの浄土系統の人々がね
念仏唱えて唱えて必死に唱えていると
なんか自分が唱えてるわけじゃないんだと
なんかこういう禅定状態ですか
第二禅定状態 よく作ったような感じがしますね
何人かには だから第二禅定作ってしまって
彼らが小休まで作ってしまって
で 阿弥陀さんが本当に出てきて
もうああだこうだとかね
言われるんだと だから彼らの修行は否定できません
だからもういい加減な修行ではなくて
本当に真面目に真剣に念仏を飲ます食わす
唱える だからこのサマーディ世界で説明していること同じく
みんなこのみんなから離れて
察す時から全部離れて
そればっかりやっている
何年もやっていると もう我というものは消えちゃうと
消えてもはっきりと彼らには阿弥陀さんがいるんですね
だから思考はあるんです
ですから第二禅定ですね
だから私たちは元々から
だからこのダルマキリという論理学者が元々からもうこれダルマキリさんとはテーラワーダ仏教の人じゃないんです
部派仏教の学者なんですけど
でも元々の教えだから
結構教養部でしょうね
世俗祭部でもないんでしたけど
なかったんだけど  彼らがやっぱりこの幻覚は幻覚としてちゃんと理解しておいてるんだから
だからそういう教育ないでしょうね
こちらで このいい加減になんとか阿弥陀様とか如来さんとかどうだとかね
もう原始的で始まるだけで
だから幻覚に囚われてしまっちゃって
それで終わっちゃうんですね
だから たとえ阿弥陀さんが現れてきて自分と握手をしたっても
あの 幻覚は幻覚なんですね
幻想は幻想であって 実際するものではありません
そこら辺はこの土片なんかは見て瞑想しちゃうと
もう明確に人は騙されませんね
自分の頭でこうやって映るんだと
なぜ映るかというと 自分には集中力はあるんだからと
それだけ だからもうあの邪見の方には陥れません
ですから 一番古い時代で書いてるこの種類瞑想っていうのはすごくいい瞑想なんですね
もし阿弥陀様を念じたら禅定は生まれますけど
だからこの邪見に陥ることは誰が助けてくれるんですかと
これ助けられません 誰にもできません
自分で阿弥陀様が見た人がいるんだったら
じゃあ話してみてください
あれは嘘やと絶対認めないんです
そういう人はいるんだから
日本で ちゃんと阿弥陀様見た
まあそういうことで まあ瞑想ですね
1番目は土  2番目はこの同じくこのアーポーカシナ
水ですね 水を見て瞑想する
これ治水家風から取ってますからね
で 水を見てこの水を見て瞑想したってもいいし
でもあんまり大きすぎて居場所座る場所がなくてとか
いろいろ問題ありますからね
で 海を見て瞑想したってもいいんだけど
やっぱり海岸の方はダメなんですね
もう激しい波があるんだから
それだったらまあ波が出てこないところに行かなくちゃいけないんですけど
ですから この何かこの
なんか作りにくいんですけどね
水だけ見えるように 何か丸い何か入れ物に水を入れて
そうすると波なんか立てませんし
そこで水を見て瞑想しなくちゃいけないんです
問題は何か入れ物に水入れちゃったら
その入れ物の外底見えちゃうんですね
どうしますか？と 水部分いないんですね
そこを何とかしなくちゃいけないんです
だからそこは黒い色だった方がいいかもしれません
黒い色で光らないと 黒い色も鏡みたいに鏡になっちゃうんです
だから鏡にならないように
に気をつけて作らなくちゃいけないんだから
ちょっと作り方は難しいんです
それで水を見て同じく瞑想するんです
定場っていうのは火ですね
で その場合は炎を見て瞑想するんですね
火を見て それも同じく普通の火を見てもよろしいし
で まあロウソクやら色々方法で
あんまり大きい円形を作るのは難しいんです
でも夜はできます 夜も夜も昼もできます
ですから この二 三時間燃えるように
もう具体的な炎でないとダメなんです
電気はダメなんです 電気で禅定は出てこないんです
ですから 色々電気であるでしょう
このなんかあの昔の薪の暖炉というんですか
暖房ですか ファイアプレイスあります
そんな感じで まあ電気で見ただけじゃ火のように見えちゃうんですね
でも問題はこれ見ただけで見えるんだと
じっと見ると火で見えなくなっちゃうでしょうに
だからそういうのは瞑想対象にはならないんですね
本当は夜徹夜してでも同じ電気だから同じ形で火が燃えているようにはなってるんだけど
そこまで自分を騙すことはできません
だから やり方は本物を見て騙すことであって
偽物を見てそれからじっと騙し続くということはできないんです
偽物をずっと見ているとどんどん騙しが消えるんですから
瞑想のやり方は本物を見て
それから騙すと それからはいくらでも騙し続けますから
これ騙すではなくて幻覚を作るんだからね
その幻覚をずっと続けられます
まあそういうわけで このまあ長い時間燃えるロウソク
1時間  2時間燃えるロウソクっていうのは
まあとても簡単に手に入るし
そういうものをつけて
その炎を見て瞑想するんです
それで目を閉じてもしっかりと炎見えるんだったら
もうこれは殊勝なんですね
ただ 目を閉じても明るいということは
それは殊勝ではないんです
はっきりと再現 できるんです
できたら殊勝で そうやって禅定を続けていくんです
次の瞑想は最も難しいんですけど
ワヨー 空気ですね で 空気を感じるという
そこは私の説明できませんですけど
あの えーと 空気っていうのは見えるもんじゃないんだけど
これ見る瞑想なんです
だから見る瞑想だから
この最初は結構難しいんだけど
そこはうまくいったら次々からは簡単です
で まあこういうこと 例えばこの修行者っていうのは
まあ森の中やらね そういう外にいるんだから
自然の中で そこで空気が
風が吹く 風が吹くと その風自体を観察して
見えるということはないんだけど
そちらに集中して もう風です
風ですと あるいはワヨー
ワヨーと と観察する 例えば木の枝がありますと
その枝が揺れるでしょ
揺れると この木の枝見るんじゃなくて
そこでこう流れてる空気を認識するんですね
その空気がずっと激しく
こうやってこうやって流れてるんだと
それでこの枝 例えば枝がこういう風にあのもう前と後ろに曲がってると
まあ空気がこうやって通ってるんだと
この空気の流れを観察する
それでまた上下に枝が行ってると
空気が下から上に行ってくんだと
台風の時でも簡単にできますけどね
そこでああ もう葉っぱが飛んでるんだということではなくて
空気自体を観察してみるんですね
風自体は 風自体はこうやって言ってるんだ
こうやって言ってるんだと
で 部屋の中にいる時でも
窓に当たるわ いろいろ音を作るわとかね
そういうところでこの自分がこのイメージするんですね
すごい巨大な力で風がこうやって流れていくんだと
まあそこでそのイメージも同じく
もう風があってもなくても
自分の心で再現できるところは殊勝で
で そこからまあどんどん二相が生まれてきて
第一禅定が生まれてくるということで
次にやるのはニイラ ピータ
ローヒタ オーダッタと４つ
ニイラっていうのは青い
オーダッタ黄色いと赤と白いという色ですね
それも同じく三十センチぐらいのこの色の乗った色の紙でもいいし
色を塗ってその色を見ているんです
青い色 黄色い色 あるいは赤い色一つだけ選ぶんです
全部ではなくて まあこの色もやっぱりこの原色から取ってる色なんですね
だから緑はないんです
緑っていうのは青いと黄色い混ぜたら緑になっちゃいますからね
そこで目を閉じてもきちんとこの色で見えてきて
同じプロセスで禅定が続けていっちゃうんです
まあ一人一人の場合はそれぞれちょっとちょっと違うところありますけど
そんな詳しく言う必要はないんですから
まあ省きますけど で 白い色っていうのは
まあすべての色をまとめた時は白色になりますから
まあそれを見て瞑想する
そこで最後に残るのはアーカーサです
もう 2つあります アーカーサ
アーカーサっていうのは空ですね
虚空 ですから あ その場合は何かあの作るというよりは何か穴掘ってみるんですね
例えば板を持ってきて三十センチぐらいの穴を掘る
穴を切ると といって この穴を見るんです
スペース見るんですね
何もないところ アローカっていうのは
あの光そのものを見る
だからこの 例えばロウソクの瞑想っていうのはすごい邪魔くさいんです
私は言ったんだけど ロウソクを炎見る場合は定常であって
ロウソクのは光として観察しちゃうと光の瞑想になっちゃうんです
光の瞑想の場合は電気でも構いません
で 何か箱を作って そちらに丸いあの穴を作って
そこをあのいくらかの何か紙を貼らないと
あのうまくいかないんです
あって この円形で光だけ見えてきます
一般的なこの白い まあ透明の紙を見がないし
まあほとんど半透明もっとあの光止まって光として見れるぐらいの何か入れて
そこから光を見てほしい
そうやって瞑想して あの集中力
あのこの三層作ればパリカンマ
ウペチャーラ パリカンマ
ウッガー ウペチャーラという三種類を組み合わせて作れば
禅定が 禅定の状態はまあ同じ状態で
まあある瞬間で まあそのものだけあって
まあ我という感覚が瞬間に消える
そうやって そういうどんな方法でも生まれるもんで
自分にやりやすいことでやっちゃえばいいということなんです
それはダッサカッシナという十種類です
次にダッサアスバという瞑想があります
このスバっていうのは物事
アスバは否定形だから
スバっていうのは物事
可愛いと綺麗と と見る見方なんです
アスバっていうのは逆に見るんです
特別な見方なんです 可愛いと綺麗と見るんじゃなくて
醜いんだと汚いんだと嫌つ
気持ち悪いという感じで見ることなんです
だからそういう瞑想というのは
ちゃんと理解してないともうやたらにやれやれというもんじゃないんです
で そこで汚いものを持ってきて
ああ汚い汚いというので
こんなもの瞑想にならないんです
ですから でもこの場合は
この本当に醜い汚いものを取って見させているんですね
で この場合の狙いはサマーディではないんです
我々のこの見方を破って
もっと違う見方もありますよと
一つの見方だけで見るんじゃないんだと
このサッキャイさんが作ったチャートで書いているだろうと思います
このアスバの場合はどこでしたっけ？禅定は優れるかないかと書いているはずなんです
第1禅定だけ生まれるんですね
それ以上はいかないんですね
2ページにあります これはどういう人々に宜しいかというと
この性格もあります 大体この人々というのはいろいろ精神的にトラブルを持ってるんですね
この解脱という輪廻脱出するという目的から見ると
なかなか束縛があって
執着があって脱出できないんですね
ですから この人の個人個人的な心の引っかかっている問題はそれぞれ違っているんです
そこで このダサアスバのあの不浄だと見る瞑想では
このどうしてもこの欲があって欲は捨てられないんですね
人間のことやら人のことやら頭に焼き付いちゃって
もうどうしようもないんですね
時々女性の方々見るんですね
まあ結構いるんですからね
女性は長生きするんだから
もう旦那が死んじゃったらもうかなり泣き崩れるんですね
だから病気になるんで
精神的に治らないほど
不思議なことは もう死んだ旦那っていうのはおじいちゃんで
もう老人ですけど だからそんなにもう欲情があって
もう泣き崩れることじゃないんだけど
それ亡くなった瞬間に浮かぶのは結婚したその時の男なんですね
そこで泣くんですね すごく優しかったとかね
楽しかったとか 頭に焼き付いてるんですね
そこを思い浮かんでもう消えない
消せません それで精神的にもおかしくなっちゃうんです
まあ男性の場合も同じことなんですけどね
例えばまあ結婚していて
また喧嘩して まあ別れてしまったと
そこでまたどんどん時間経つと
また相手のことをなんとなく気に入ってしまっちゃうとかね
やっぱり自分が悪かったとかね
その時いろいろまた泣いたり悲しがったりするんだけど
頭に浮かぶ映像は何ですかというと
結婚したその時の人の映像なんですね
離婚した時の人の映像じゃないんです
思い浮かぶ そこは問題なんですね
結婚したその時の優しさとか
その時の美しさとか そこを浮かんだりする
もし離婚した瞬間の映像がずっと頭にあったならば
もう全然悲しくも何にもない
もう離婚してよかったと
ということでなっちゃいますけど
そうはならなくなっちゃうと
ということは これはごく普通に世の中にある人間の精神的な病気なんですね
だからおばあちゃんにしたっても
まあおばあさん まあなんておじいさんが亡くなったら
その亡くなった瞬間の映像を
その一番最近の情報だけ
一番新しい情報だけ頭に入れておくと
何の苦しみも何もないんです
だからまあ死ぬということも生きていられない
生きていられないということでしょうに
病気になって倒れて もう自分でも不自由になってしまって
どうしようもない状態でもう死んじゃうでしょうに
だから決して死んだ人にしても
見守っていた人々にしても
もう手に負えない状態でしょうに
だから本当は死んだんですかとホッとする瞬間のはずなのに
だから死んだことを思い出すと気持ちよくなるはずなんです
あ よかったと あれ あれでよかったという思い
本当は面白く楽しく思い出せるはずなんですけど
人間は逆ですね まあみんな病気だから
その時はものすごい古い情報が頭に浮かんじゃうんですね
だからそれはおかしいんです
人間の思考の過程を見ると
だから精神的に悩んだり苦しんだりすること自体があまりにもおかしいんです
仏教から見ると 人が死んじゃったんだからと泣くとかね
それおかしいと たとえ子供が死んだっても
死んだということは 子供
その子供にとっては生きていられない状態になったんだからね
例えば子供が事故を起こしちゃったと
そこで小さな子供かもしれません
もう足も潰れて もう胸もあっちこっち傷だらけで
浅層も傷だらけで 頭も潰れてとかね
そこでなんとか修理して生き返ってきたっても
立派な健康な人間では生きていられない
一生障害者になるし まあ障害者ででも生きていられるならば生きていられますでしょう
生き延びれますから たとえ障害者としてでも生きていられない場合は死ぬんだから
やっぱり死んだ方がいいんですね
その子にとっても楽でしょうし
あの看病する人々にとっても
それでよかったという状態なんですけど
その最新の情報を見るんじゃなくて
小さい時はこうかわいくて
あっち走ったりこっち走ったり遊んだりして
自分の体に飛んできて乗ってくることやらね
そういうことばっかり思い浮かんで病気になって崩れちゃうんですね
だから人間がそうやって悲しむのはすごい論理的に見ると
心理学的に見ても変なんですね
これは何とか直さなくちゃいけない
一般人にはこれ無理ですね
だから特別な頭のいい人々にこれを教えてるんです
これは変な だから本当に世の中見ちゃうと
どんな状況でもこれで良かったということなんですけど
そうはならないんですから
そこであすばっていうのは
このこちらであって この仏教の場合
この場合はすごいレベル高い次元で物事を見てるんですね
ただ 自分の死んだ子供に対して
死んだ旦那さんに対して欲を捨てるためという単純なことじゃないんです
そうではなくて 人って何ですか？我々は人にとってすごく欲を持って
自分って何ですか？と
ものすごい欲を持って
執着を持って あれやりたい
これやりたい ああだこうだと偉そうに生きてるんだけど
一体全体生きるということは何ですかと
と理解するためと同時に
もう欲が消えてしまう
それで遺体を見るんですね
死んだ遺体を見る 遺体は死にませんね
で 遺体を見るんですね
遺体を見る瞬間で わさわさとこれ不浄やと思わなくてもいいんです
なぜならば あ これ可愛いと抱いたいと誰も思わないんです
遺体を見ると なんとなく不思議な気持ちなんですね
なんとなく空しい気持ちとかね
この何も動きはしない
単なる物体で で 思う ゆかでもこの人はよくよく喋っていたんだと
よくよく冗談言ってよく金儲けていたんだとかね
よく仕事をして部下にもう怒ったり喧嘩したり
いろいろなことをしたんだけどさ
こんな調子やって 今はね
何もできなくて もうただもう物体になって横になっているだけですから
そうやって遺体を見る
だから遺体を見るって言ったって
これ10種類ありますから
どんどんどんどん見続けなくちゃいけないんです
だから 1 日目  2 日目  3 日目とかね
で そこでどのように瞑想するかというと
見て まあ余計なことをね
この人素晴らしかったとかね
やっぱり今は来てないんだけど
すごいかっこいい人でしたとか
そんなことを考えるんじゃなくて
そうすると変でしょうね
情報が じゃなくて 今はこの調子ですと
この生きていた人が 生きてる私もこの調子になるんだと
例えばこの体の血やら全部この腐ってきて
鼻から目から出始めるんです
死んだら2日 3日目になるとこれ膨らむんです
膨張しちゃうんです それで膨張しちゃうと
もうあ すごい格好良くないんです
死んだその瞬間では全然もう寝ているような感じですけど
2日目になってくるともう膨らんでいるんですね
腫れてるんで 全部 うん
まあ生きてる私もそんな調子になるんだと
今日瞑想言葉っていうのは
ヤタエイダン ヤタエイダン
タタエイダンというちょっと難解な言葉なんです
ヤタエイダン これは何でしょうか？こちらも同じで
それぐらいの意味の言葉なんですね
そこでこちらあまり説明ないんだから
私も説明はしませんだけど
こちらで書いてる10種類っていうのは
現代我々にはなかなか残念ながら瞑想できませんですけど
不浄観はね あまりにも変ですからね
世界は ごまかすと隠すということだから
人が死んじゃったらもう
もうアメリカも酷いでしょうしね
ものすごいお化粧するんですね
綺麗にもう顔色とかもう口紅
目 ああだこうだとかものすごいもう生きてたよりはものすっごくもう綺麗に見えるように
ここら辺だけ 色々な色を塗ったりとかね
まあ死んだんだから別に遠慮する必要もないし
これ皮膚にいいか悪いかとかね
見る必要もないし あの普通のスプレーペイントでもやっちゃうんです
例えばそちらの傷跡あったら
ちゃんと何となくスプレーペイントでそれは
だからあんなごまかしはね
何のためにやるかと どこまで幻覚